dieser neu entdeckte exoplanet ist da wo
er eigentlich gar nicht hingehört denn
der himmelskörper mit der bezeichnung
ngt svp umkreist seinen stern viel zu
nah befindet sich also in einer region
in der bislang noch nie zuvor einen
exoplaneten aufgespürt werden konnte und
nicht nur das trotz der widrigen
bedingungen dort wie starker uv und
röntgenstrahlung und sonnen wilden
besitzt eine eigene atmosphäre
wie kann dieser verbotene planet
existieren klicks und sein sandwich gibt
es täglich faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen der jetzt
aufgespürte exoplaneten gts 4b hat etwa
die 20 fache masse unserer erde und ist
etwa dreimal so groß wie sie der
himmelskörper umrundet science
werkstätten mgs4 der etwa 900 lichtjahre
von uns entfernt sind gerade einmal 32
stunden das ist wirklich eine sehr kurze
zeit wenn man das beispielsweise man mit
der erde vergleicht die für die
umkreisung ihres sterns bekanntlich ein
jahr braucht und sogar der innerste
planet unseres sonnensystems merkur
braucht ganze 88 tage um die sonne zum
laufen ein internationales
forschungsteam hatte den exoplaneten ngt
es 4 b durch auswertung von daten der
chilenischen eng gts anlage aufspüren
können ngt es ist die abkürzung für next
generation transit server exoplaneten
denn insgesamt zwölf teleskope die
automatisch arbeiten suche nach planeten
in anderen sonnensystemen auch das
deutsche zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt
dlr ist hier mit am start
das internationale astronomenteam kamen
dem äußerst mysteriösen exoplaneten
durch die sogenannten transitmethode auf
die schliche bei diesem verfahren wird
danach ausschau halten ob sich die
helligkeit eines sterns ändert denn dies
könnte ein hinweis darauf sein dass von
der erde aus gesehen an planet direkt
vor seinem stern vorbeizieht und somit
ein teil des lichts blockiert dies
geschah bei der aktuellen sensations-
entdeckung allerdings nur in minimalem
ausmaß der stern wurde gerade einmal 0,3
zehn prozent dunkler als 600 an ihm
vorbeizog wirklich bemerkenswert dass er
dennoch von einem bodengestützten
instrument entlarvt werden konnte
fachleute weltweit bezeichnen diese in
der
nicht nur deswegen als sensation denn er
neu aufgespürte verbotene planet wie er
mittlerweile schon genannt wird wie der
setzt sich quasi dem atmosphären
striptease denn normalerweise dürfte ein
planet der so nah an seinem
zentralgestirn seine bahn zieht keine
atmosphäre haben den planeten in der
nähe eines sterns müssen mit extrem
starke uv-strahlung sonnenwinde und
röntgenstrahlung einiges aushalten
zwar wurden in einer solch geringen
entfernung zum einen bereits die
planeten in der größe von jupiter und
zum anderen auch so kleine planeten wie
der mars aufgespürt heißt also in
unserer galaxie gibt es offensichtlich
bevorzugt zwei arten vom planeten zum
einen kleine steinige supererden und zum
anderen gasreiche heiße mini neptun oder
jupiter planeten mit einer zwischen
größe dagegen sind kaum vorhanden
deswegen sprechen fachleute von der
sogenannten neptun wüste und meinen
damit die lücke zwischen supererden und
neptun großen planeten doch der neu
entdeckten exoplaneten dts 4b füllt
diese lücke jetzt somit ist der neu
entdeckte exoplanet ein echtes novum
dazu der astronom richard west der
planet muss ziemlich hart im nehmen sein
da sich in einem bereich in dem netten
große planeten nicht überleben können
befindet alle bisherigen planeten dieser
größe und in solch einer region waren
also entweder so groß wie der jupiter
und konnten durch ihre große masse eine
starke anziehungskraft auf ihre
atmosphäre ausüben und diese für sich
behalten oder aber sie waren so klein
wieder maß und danone atmosphäre
zumindest bei einem vergleichbaren
abstand zu ihrem stern dazu heißt es vom
dlr
normalerweise würde ein planet mit der
masse des neptuns und einer ähnlichen
zusammensetzung durch die starke
strahlung einwirkung des stern sehr
schnell seine hülle aus wasserstoff und
helium verlieren und nur der kern bliebe
übrig die experten und expertinnen haben
aber auch eine mögliche erklärung für
ihren sensations- von parat dazu der
planetenforscher philipp müller vom dlr
wahrscheinlich hat ngt svb nur überlebt
weil er einen besonders großen kern
besitzt oder weil er erst später in
diese kurze entfernung zu seinem stern
hinein gewandert ist als dessen
strahlung schon etwas abgeklungen war
die neue entdeckung lässt die fachleute
hoffen dass in den bereits
aufgezeichneten
hatten der chilenischen ngt es anlage
weitere ähnliche himmelskörper in der
neptun küste aufgespürt werden können
dazu der astronom richard west
möglicherweise ist die wüste grüne als
bislang gedacht
am 20 juli berichten wird zwölf stunden
lang quasi live von der mondlandung vor
50 jahren sekundengenau die astronauten
gerd thiele und reinhold ewald sind
dabei und zahlreiche wissenschafts
youtuber wie astro comics tv raum zeit
wirkt der zukunft breaking lab der
medizinstudent doktor watson und neugier
zone es wird extrem spannend wenn er
nichts verpassen wollt dann klickt hier
und merkt euch den steam forum 21 uhr am
samstag den 20 juli geht es los bis dann
bleibt dran